So what I just showed you is
the basic Lukas-Kanade method.
kind of elegant.
Basically, we've made
a lot of assumptions, and
these assumptions can give us errors.
The biggest error we have, that is
the assumption that we made that's,
in some sense, the most wrong,
is the idea that the motion is small.
Okay?
Often, motion is large.
And when motion is large,
a couple of things are wrong
with the Taylor expansion.
One is even if things are nice and
smooth, they may not be linear.
So we were doing a first order,
Taylor expansion, not a second order.
No second derivatives here.
So that assumes that things are planar.
Well, suppose things
are curved a little bit.
Well, we, we're going to handle that.
In fact, we're going to talk
about that in a minute.
By doing something called
iterative refinement.
Which is, we're going to
assume it's a plane, solve it.
Move the picture over a little bit.
Do it again, do it again, do it again,
until we've converged finally to the,
to the right point.
And its, allows us to handle
the non-planar component.
But in some sense, even much more worse.
Much more worse?
Even worse than that, is maybe,
I've got a nice bright pixel here and
then the bright pixel jumps
over a bunch of dark pixels.
So it's not even, and then there's some
other, so it's not even local anymore.
That is, I can't find my, my ni,
the, where I went by just sort
of following my derivatives.
And the way we're going to handle
that is with a course define method
which actually we're
going to do next lesson.
Today, the on, the, this lesson,
the only remaining thing we're going to
talk about is this iterative refinement.
So, iterative refinement is
designed to handle the fact
that things are not exactly tangent.
And so, here's how it works.
I'll write down the algorithm.
And then it's a lot easier
to see in a picture.
All right?
So, the first thing is,
the way you do it is,
you say okay, I'm going to pretend.
I'm good at pretending,
that it's just going to work.
All right?
So, I solve for my velocities
using the standard Lukas-Kanade.
So I find,
I assume linear Taylor approximation.
I solve for u, v.
Great.
So, now I've got a u, v at every pixel.
Now, it says I'm going to
warp It to It plus 1.
Okay.
We talked about doing image warping
when we were applying transformations.
And those of you who
are going to do the problem set,
you'll probably get to know and
love how to do warping.
But basically, the u,
v says how to move every pixel from
one image to get to the next one.
So you know what?
I take this picture and
I move all the pixels.
And if you remember,
we have to do this backward warp so
we don't end up with holes.
If you don't remember that,
go back to the transformation lecture
where we talked about warping.
But the idea is that we
essentially distort the,
the t image to move to where
I think all the pixels go.
So it's almost the t plus one image.
But it's not exactly the t
plus one image, is it?
It's close.
So what do I do?
I just do it again.
I take the image that I created and
I compare that to the real
t plus one image.
And I get a small amount of more motion.
I could actually add that
motion to the original motion.
That's the new flow field.
Well, I can take that one I created.
Move it a little bit.
And what do I do?
Do it again.
Until the pixels stop moving,
and that will it,
that will converge to a solution.
So that's really easier
seeing here graphically.